the impact of September 11 this event
from Emory University in Atlanta is an
hour Richard Preston needs little
introduction his bestseller the hot zone
about the Ebola virus put him on the map
the hot zone continues to be widely read
many of you may may or may not know but
it is used as a text both in English
classes and in science classes in many
high schools across the country it says
volumes I think about his ability to
communicate he has more recently turned
his attention to this right of
bioterrorism and it's fictional book of
bioterrorism the Cobra event kept
President Clinton awake especially when
the president learned that the book was
largely based on fact a subsequent
article on smallpox in the New York or
two years ago one Richard Preston the
national magazine award for public
interest he also has received an award
for CDC for his championship for Public
Health we're quite fortunate to have
Richard Preston talked to us tonight
about his current work and let's give
him a warm welcome
thank you very much Ruth and thank you
all for your wonderful warm reception in
your turn out I'm really truly honored
by this and and feel very very welcomed
by my friends at the Centers for Disease
Control my friends in the public health
community we have I have friends here
from the army as well and it is a great
privilege to address you tonight my
subject is the reality of biological
weapons which is absolutely a reality it
was not considered so much of a reality
not very long ago but now it is my work
is a writer largely focuses on
nonfiction writing telling true stories
I love to explore human deeds and the
human experience through science itself
science is a magnificent quest and it is
also deeply human with all of the human
flaws that we know only too well being
human beings ourselves the the smallpox
virus is the central subject and central
character of the demon in the freezer
smallpox is an organism that once lived
in nature and was exclusively a parasite
of a human body today it exists
officially in two locations on the
planet one here in Atlanta at the CDC in
the maximum containment lab and the
other location is in Siberia at a
research lab called vector unofficially
smallpox is thought to reside in bio
warfare lab
and an unknown number of countries
around the world countries that may
include Iraq and may include indeed
Russia itself which may possess
undeclared stocks of smallpox virus in
military facilities where it was once
stockpiled in tonnage quantities for use
as a weapon in warheads that may have
been targeted on the United States and
intercontinental ballistic missiles
where that smallpox is today is not
entirely known and there have not been
entire entirely forthcoming assurances
from the government of the Russian
Federation about that something like
10,000 years ago smallpox or varela
jumped out of some unknown animal into
its first human host it was an emerging
virus that entered the human species
probably at the dawn of Agriculture at a
time when human populations were
increasing dramatically and people were
tending to cluster along river valleys
agricultural river valleys the virus
needs a population of about 200,000
people who live within about a 10-day
travel time from one another in order to
sustain itself in human populations
today the virus in effect has forgotten
its original host and is not known to
infect any any organism other than human
beings varela has become a part of us in
a way that we cannot seem to get rid of
on September 11 2001 I was working on a
number of projects none of which had
anything to do with biological weapons I
felt that I had a department from that
subject and I was eagerly looking
forward to writing something else and I
was at work on a book I happen to live
in a small town just outside princeton
new jersey and from a hill in my town
you can look out and you can see lower
manhattan and you can see where the
World Trade Center used to be when the
World Trade Center fell down in the
terror attacks I went up on that hill
and stood in silence with a number of
people from the neighborhood and we
watched an enormous plume of black smoke
coming out of Manhattan and drifting
about 50 miles to the southeast until it
just vanished somewhere over the
Atlantic Ocean in following days the
plume went over princeton repeatedly and
you could smell it it was an
unforgettable smell and to me it was a
smell of destruction and war indeed all
of the public schools all of the schools
in our area both public and private with
very few exceptions lost at least one
parent from the school and there was one
school that johnson park school in
princeton that lost three parents that
was an elementary school most of these
schools most of the parents were parents
of younger children because they were
working in the financial district i
ended up feeling absolutely unable to
move forward as a writer and i think
that this must have happened to many
people in the creative arts in the
united states I felt in a way that I had
I had gotten a case of spiritual
laryngitis I didn't know what to say
what could one say to the public at a
time like this that could be meaningful
and what what is the purpose what does
one's purpose is a writer anyway what am
I here for and I really I didn't know
what to do I really I had to reach back
and think a lot about what exactly I was
trying to do as a writer here and I
thought about
some of my training actually came to
mind and I'm going to talk to you a
little bit during the course of these
remarks about how I work as a reporter
how I get information from people how I
take notes how I work as a writer as I
write about scientists my background is
in English literature I have a PhD in
English from Princeton University where
I studied and I decided at some point
that I didn't want to go into the
academic world but i wanted to write and
for me nothing was more fascinating than
science my models really stemmed from my
inability to pass my latin exams you
were required to pass Latin in those
days to get the doctorate and I flunked
it three times in a row and I had to
keep coming back studying more lat and
taking the exam again and then
afterwards I was determined not to
forget my Latin so I began reading Latin
for pleasure in reading the classics and
i discovered the great Roman Latin
historian Tacitus and rettenmund Latin
and found that he has a way of
describing a very important events that
were occurring at the time of the Roman
Empire with a rather quiet very simple
style in which he can elicit human
character very quickly with just a few
little sketches and it's deeply
interesting and the story always moves
forward with a kind of tremendous drama
from there I went back farther in time
and I read through Sid ADIZ facilities
is considered to be the first modern
historian he lived at the time of
Pericles in ancient Rome he just to give
you an idea of what he was like he was a
general in the Athenian army and he lost
a battle and was fired during the
Peloponnesian War he was almost killed
and he was exiled for a while he had to
go to Sparta great enemy of Athens where
he had nothing better to do but right
about these
of his day and so he began interviewing
Spartan soldier's and generals and he
went back to Athens and began
interviewing Athenian commanders and
figures and he gradually put together as
he says in his book you know a complete
account of what he felt was the most
important event of his time he was in
fact but in modern terms he was a
nonfiction reporter doing much like what
I do today he was interviewing people
and he was trying to find out what they
said what happened and putting it
together into a context that's both
dramatic and tells about our time as I
thought about this I really i finally
decided that I absolutely had to take
some of the work that I've been doing
and write about biological weapons none
was more important than smallpox the the
other thing that happened was that when
the anthrax terror event occurred I
began realizing that I knew many of the
people who were involved in the
investigation of these crimes my
previous book is a novel bioterrorism
novel the Cobra vented lots of
background sources including a bunch of
people in the FBI people at CDC I spent
quite a bit of time hanging out with
epidemic intelligence service officers
at the CDC these are younger researchers
who do a two-year tour of duty with the
CDC and one of them was a woman by the
name of cindy r friedman md who was at
that time an EIS officer and then some
FBI people including a guy named David
Wilson I hung out with and an FBI
scientist named Randy merge Randall has
merch Cindy Friedman is now a member of
the FBI investigative anthrax team she's
officially a member of America too and I
think she's been sworn in as a deputy
marshal I believe us deputy and David
Wilson is the head
the anthrax science group at the
Washington field office and Randy merch
is the guy who kind of grandfathered the
whole idea that bioterrorism was really
going to happen and the FBI had to do
something to get ready for it I was
sitting one evening in Quantico they
have a there's a bar there which they
call the boardroom and in the evening
you can get a beer there and I was
sitting around with a bunch of FBI
people talking about bioterrorism and
they went on at great length about
modern techniques of forensic science
that could be used to track down an
anthrax terrorist or a terrorist and how
with subtle tools and advanced
technology you could use this to
construct an image of the perpetrator
through the menu details of the crime
fast-forward to the present day I'm
sitting in the office of David Wilson
now at the FBI headquarters at the field
office in Washington and he is he had
nothing at all to say about forensic
evidence he said you know I fear that
for all of our optimism it's looking
more and more like we're going to have
to solve this case through classic shoe
leather detective work we're going to
need a witness we're going to need
something we're going to need a break
the science so far has failed the FBI
and I recall random urge the FBI
scientists sitting in the boardroom
drinking a beer and saying ultimately
human beings are human and they make
mistakes and that's how crimes are
solved and so we find out that the
reality of bioterrorism has turned out
to be quite a bit different than
everybody imagined it would be at least
in terms of solving the crime in the
demon in the freezer the way I make the
jump from anthrax to smallpox which is
rather a difficult thing to do is
through
the personality and thinking and actions
of dr. Peter Charlie from the United
States Army Medical Research Institute
of infectious diseases you samer it
Peter darling I've known for many years
he's a top virologist there who has
become deeply involved with smallpox
research and preparation for bio
preparation bioterrorism preparation for
smallpox in the event we ever deal with
it I've known him for many years and the
way I link this in the book is there's
this moment when right after the letter
that was mailed to Senator Tom Daschle
was opened in in the hart senate office
building and a very small amount of fine
powder came out of the letter the powder
had been treated effectively with modern
techniques to make it of an effective
biological weapon and a good deal of
that powder went up into the air and
then absolutely dispersed and filled the
building like a gas it went everywhere
that's why the hart senate office
building was so difficult to clean up
because the spores had simply gone
everywhere as i learned later there is
an admixture of a material in that
anthrax known in the pharmaceutical
industry as an excipient and it's a
little additive it is very finely
powdered silica glass it's a particular
kind of glass it's my understanding
known as a nanopowder nano silica powder
you can order it on the internet the
trick of mixing glass into powdered
anthrax spores appears to be a military
trick that may have been discovered
independently by Americans working in
the old US biological weapons program
and later by Soviets glass and anthrax
is something known to be a weapon ears
trick so the person who made this
anthrax somebody quite knowledgeable
about how to do it and may well have had
access to a formula Peter darling was
one of the people who initially began to
think about
these forensic samples as they came into
use amrit from the FBI the FBI
ultimately made you Sam read the
repository of the federal evidence for
these crimes or for much of the federal
evidence I should say and journaling
immediately began to think yeah but what
if this powder had a few particles of
smallpox virus mixed into it what if
this is a mixed weapon what if the
anthrax is a kind of Trojan horse that
that lets smallpox essentially out into
the human population of Capitol Hill
what then and I moved from there to to
the story of smallpox and we go to a
hospital in Germany where we find out
that one man with smallpox who was
undiagnosed ended up infecting twenty
percent of the people in the hospital
both staff and patients alike and most
of them were in upper floors and all but
one had never seen his face and we go
from there to the story of the
eradication when you're writing about
science when you're talking about
science it's one way to do it is to
approach it through human beings and to
talk about what drives the scientists
what the scientist is thinking about and
how that person is interacting
essentially with the forces of nature
around in this case the ultimate force
is smallpox itself a life-form which is
the the dark protagonist of this book
and when you're reporting stories with
people you you learn what works and what
doesn't work as a reporter and I've been
doing this for many years now I was
trained i had a virtual apprenticeship
with the author john mcphee who is a
professor at Princeton University and
you may know him as the author of
something like 25 books many of which
have been published in the pages of
New Yorker magazine he's a very
distinguished writer and an excellent
teacher and he taught me some tricks and
I'm about to describe you one i'm going
to describe at the expense of my army
friends and i'm so sorry but the very
first interview that I did when I was
working on the hot zone was with Colonel
Nancy Jax and Peter darling drifting
drifted into the interview not too long
after that and Nancy Jax began talking
about working with Ebola virus in a
biosafety biohazard spacesuit and I said
well do things ever go wrong isn't it
scary and she said oh well yeah you know
we all have our close calls and one day
I was you know I was working in my suit
and I discovered that I had a crack in
the glove and I could feel hee hee bola
infected blood from a monkey sloshing
around inside the suit of mice the
sleeve of my spacesuit and I happen to
have a band-aid on on the palm of my
hand because I'd cut my hand while I was
opening a can of beans for the children
the night before cooking dinner for them
and John McPhee taught me that when
somebody says something explosive are
really interesting you can put your
notes down and pretend not to be taking
any notes I only work with notes on
paper I virtually never use a tape
recorder because I'm a technical idiot
and the Machine always needs to tape and
then you have to transcribe it and more
importantly when you're using a tape
recorder you find that you have you have
the sound is captured but you forget so
much else about a scene you forget the
color of people's eyes you forget what
exactly what their body mannerisms were
when they were talking you forget the
whole context of the scene if you're
concentrating on a tape recorder but if
you use just handwritten notes alone you
get it all in the notes then you can
recreate it in a piece of vivid and
realistic writing so anyway that the
technique is that if
say something really explosive you put
your notes down and you begin you turn
on a little short term memory buffer in
your brain and you begin trying to
remember what they're saying word for
word without writing it down and then
when you feel your little short term
memory filling up then you change the
subject and you ask them a question that
you know is going to have a boring
answer and you begin writing like mad
and you're dumping the memory buffer of
what they just said so I did this with
Nancy Jackson just as I was finishing up
with the boring question Peter jarring
happened to be in the room and he said
yes and you know we all have had things
like that and he said I I realize I'm
talking to a journalist and I probably
ought not to be saying this but you know
I inadvertently happened to inhale a
small amount of Ebola virus from a flask
I didn't realize what was in the flask
and afterwards you know I was a little
bit nervous about that and I I started
testing my blood every day because I
didn't want to be put into the slammer I
wanted to do the science on the virus
Ebola this lamber is the bio containment
lab and once again i put my notes down
and just stopped writing and listened
and got that scene as well that was the
very first interview i did with these
two individuals together when things
like that happen in reporting it's quite
magical there's a wonderful sensation
that in a way you're finding out about
things that nobody knows about that
they're compelling extremely interesting
and ultimately in in terms of biology
writing about things I read about very
important for all of our lives each and
every one of us is touched but by the
microscopic world of nature that exists
entirely around us that we can never
escape and we're always a part of and
the people in my books Peter darling
Nancy Jack's people from the CDC who
have appeared in various places in my
writing are in fact they are I don't
have bad
people in my right for the most large
part they're heroes but they're often
quiet heroes they're the sort of people
who don't normally ask for attention for
themselves they don't normally demand
attention and they often don't think
they deserve it and people will often
say to me you know i really don't know
why you're writing about me you know i'm
really not very interesting and when
somebody says that you know a little red
light goes off what that means is that
person is very interesting but they may
not quite understand the dimensions of
interest in them as a character when
you're writing about scientists you
often find that scientists initially
have very very uncomfortable reactions
if they're described vividly and a piece
of writing because they feel in a way
that their work as scientists is much
more important than who they are as a
person they'll be gone but the body of
work will remain and they can't
understand why a journalist wants to
know what type of car the scientist
drives or whether the hair is parted on
the left or writer you know what color
their eyes are but all these details
just these tiny little details of human
beings are what make a piece of writing
come alive to all readers we read books
because we want more than just the
scientific information we also want a
kind of spiritual nourishment that can
only come in finding out and learning
about the challenges that other people
face and what they do to overcome them
the challenge of smallpox is that it is
truly a horrific parasite of humans I
think it is considered by many doctors
to be the worst disease of humans it is
believed nobody knows it is believed to
have killed perhaps a billion people in
the last hundred years or so of its
existence on the earth from roughly 1878
1877 to 1977 when the last natural
human case of smallpox occurred the
particles are have a kind of eerie
beauty to them if you look at them in an
electron microscope they are very
complicated this is an extremely
complicated virus it expresses around
200 different proteins it has around 200
active genes in it the genome is close
to 200,000 letters of DNA base pairs of
DNA long in comparison to the AIDS virus
which is some 6,500 letters of DNA one
scientist said to me that the AIDS virus
is a bicycle a really well designed
bicycle and the smallpox virus is a
Hummer with all the options
they accomplished their goals
biologically through entirely different
means but and one does it by just
throwing in everything but the kitchen
sink to try to do something to disturb
the human immune system enough this is
smallpox so that it can multiply
unopposed in its host and the AIDS virus
does other things in other ways the to
think about the potential of smallpox
today is really pretty eerie and
frightening the United States government
now is involved in a crash effort to
produce a stockpile of the traditional
vaccine there there should be enough for
everybody relatively soon if there isn't
already the traditional vaccine was
essentially developed in 1796 Thomas
Jefferson recommended it highly to the
American people and it has proved to be
a very effective vaccine over the years
against the smallpox virus however
elsewhere in the world there is
absolutely not enough vaccine available
when the virus was eradicated the
feeling among public health doctors was
that this was an eradicated disease and
in their innocence and in their optimism
about the human spirit having just
achieved something truly noble and
remarkable in in the history of Medicine
the eradication the very first
eradication of an infectious disease and
the eradication of this one they
intellectually and imaginatively could
not really conceived of the idea that
anybody would be capable of using this
and deploying it as a weapon to kill
other people and in 1991 a committee of
the World Health Organization had to
consider what to do with the World
Health Organization's existing stockpile
of smallpox vaccine it was a large
stockpile was being kept in some
freezers known as the GAR refrigerate in
Geneva
and the committee recommended that
ninety nine point seven five percent of
the stockpile of vaccine be destroyed in
order to save about twenty-five thousand
dollars a year in largely an electricity
costs that were for running the freezers
that were keeping the vaccines stored
and well the vaccine today the World
Health Organization's stockpile of
smallpox vaccine amounts to the
equivalent of one dose of the vaccine
for every twelve thousand people on the
planet if smallpox were to be released
in the united states in a bioterror act
and if a few americans were infected
with smallpox and it weren't stamped out
immediately by vaccination strategies of
one kind or another then there is the
possibility that the virus could leave
the united states and go elsewhere
people travel a lot in this world if it
were to go to a place like bangladesh
india populous nations in Africa places
where there is very little public health
infrastructure to begin with and no
vaccine available it could be a very bad
situation it is taken HIV about 20 years
to reach your reported 50 million human
cases worldwide given what we know about
smallpox we can suppose that smallpox
could do the same thing in about 15 to
20 weeks if it went global the for the
American people the issue now is is the
problem of the vaccine itself being not
very good for some people who take it
the vaccine is known to have some
low-level background rate of bad
reactions in apparently healthy
populations in our population today
there are large numbers of people who
have
depressed immune function for one reason
or another and they they are thought to
be at higher risk of contracting a very
bad reaction to the vaccine these are
people such as people who have had
chemotherapy people who are taking
immune suppression drugs such as
prednisone people who are HIV positive
who may or may not know that they're HIV
positive the the population at risk
apparently also includes people who have
a history of eczema or people who are
pregnant women small children and
infants so there's a large segment of
the human population that really you
know by modern standards in modern
safety standards and under normal
circumstances the FDA would not licensed
the vaccine for these people what is
there going to be for them if we have a
bioterror attack in the United States
and if it becomes necessary to vaccinate
large numbers of people all at once and
in terms of numbers what I've heard is
that it there's a huge debate going on
right now about the infectivity of
smallpox its ability to move through
modern human populations and there is a
wide divergence of opinions some feel
that smallpox is not very contagious
could be very easily contained with
modest ring vaccination vaccinating
people in a ring around an outbreak
tracking cases and and stamping out the
virus that way others feel that the
virus would be extremely difficult to
control in a society where people travel
a lot where they go to shopping malls
where they take airplanes with a commute
and so on there there are no answers to
this question really and we won't know
unless the real thing happens so what
are we going to do if it becomes
necessary to vaccinate a whole lot of
people all at once some experts feel
that if there were say ten to a hundred
cases of smallpox in in the United
States as a result of a bioterror attack
it might be necessary to
vaccinate as many as 40 million
Americans very quickly in order to stop
the outbreak and it might be necessary
to vaccinate just about everybody who
can tolerate the vaccine that brings us
to the story in the demon in the freezer
which is the story of scientific
research and a big part of the story is
is the description of the work of a team
of army scientists who are working in
the maximum containment lab at the CDC
to develop begin the work of developing
bio defenses against smallpox that do
not require the traditional vaccine this
team the principal investigator is Peter
Charlie and there are a number of people
on this team and I'd like to mention
them very honored that a number of them
are here tonight the team includes John
Huggins Lieutenant Colonel mark martinez
a veterinary pathologist I don't believe
he's here tonight dr. Lisa Hensley PhD
microbiologist and public health doctor
public health mmph and Josh shamblin I
don't know if he's here and Jim Stockman
who is a professional animal technician
who has been working for many years at
Fort Detrick with animal experimentation
these people have engaged in what I
think is a very dramatic an important
piece of scientific research which is
the quest to find initially to find an
animal model for smallpox so that new
drugs and a new modern vaccine can be
tested for use in human populations the
need for a smallpox antiviral drug is
extremely real right now one reason we
need it is because there are all these
people who perhaps can't tolerate the
vaccine another reason we need it is
people who are having a bad
action to the traditional vaccine could
probably be treated successfully with an
antiviral drug if it works on smallpox
could easily work on the vaccine as well
and finally there is the undefinable but
I think very real possibility that the
smallpox virus could be genetically
engineered to partially or largely evade
the vaccine that has become in the last
year or so a distinct possibility for
these reasons we need a smallpox drug a
drug would most likely attack the core
machinery of a smallpox virus and would
therefore be effective against any type
of engineer it's smallpox that comes
down the pike because the engineering of
a virus would probably have to be in in
terms of putting a gene or two into it
to make it express certain proteins that
confuse the human immune system this
would be the type of genetic engineering
that could be done on smallpox but the
core machinery in the virus can still be
wrecked by a good antiviral drug the
work is very difficult to contemplate
because what we have here is we have
scientists infecting monkeys with real
smallpox human smallpox and in some
cases these animals developed the all of
the symptoms of human smallpox disease
they postulate just the way humans do
they get their bodies can be covered
with blisters and human beings in
classical ordinary smallpox your body
erupts in these hard very dry pustules
especially over the face and extremities
these pustules are said by smallpox
doctors to have a to feel like a shotgun
pellets embedded in this
in there deep seated they're rock hard
extremely painful and and in some way
shape or form the virus causes death in
human beings but the exact cause of
death was smallpox virus is in fact
unknown to science there's much that is
unknown about the smallpox virus so we
have these scientists working in the
laboratory and I have in my notes you
know repeated descriptions from them of
the painful difficulty of infecting
animals with this virus for one thing
the virus is exclusively a human
parasite and the issue between us and
smallpox is very much a human thing and
yet here we are giving the virus to
monkeys at the same time if we don't do
it literally perhaps millions of human
lives are at stake here with this
research so it is felt I think
profoundly by the scientists doing this
research that though it is painful it
has to go forward and the quest is one
that is absolutely reasonable the food
and drug administration simply requires
that there be at least one successful
animal model of smallpox before it will
license any drug or probably new vaccine
for use in the public that's the
requirement and the scientists are doing
it I'm reminded of the paintings of
thomas eakins the painting a painter
whom i greatly admire he's an american
realist from the 19th century some of
you may have seen his paintings he was
in fact a kind of nonfiction painter he
does he did in paint what I try to do in
words he he dramatized the beauty and
the splendor and the kind of dramatic
sometimes dramatic horror of real
American life he's got a famous painting
the gross clinic that he may have seen
the painting is titled after a doctor
named gross but the clinic itself is
pretty gross and in it he graphically
depicts an early surgical operation in
which a patient has been anesthetized
dr. gross is standing next to this
patient who has opened up and there's
blood all over the place the patient is
nude and in dr. grossest inning there
he's lecturing to an amphitheater of
professionals his hands are covered with
blood and he's illuminated in the light
and he's this tremendous figure and then
in the foreground we see a nurse who
cannot take what she's looking at in the
painting she's covering her eyes like
this and her hands are like claws and
she can't look but she does look at the
same time and this is the kind of
feeling that I get when I think about
this very dramatic work with smallpox in
the maximum containment lab it's
scientifically important it's extremely
dramatic I think it talks to the public
in a way and it's extremely important
and it tells us something about who we
are and why we exist and what's
important about not only bio defense but
about science itself the the book
concludes with a visit back to Fort
Detrick where I go into the lab with
some of the scientists on this team and
at Fort Detrick they have a human arm
preserved human arm which is covered
with smallpox pustules it is the arm of
a three-year-old child who died of
smallpox Burrell a major probably about
50 years ago we don't know if the child
was male or female a child is Caucasian
may well have died somewhere in the
American Midwest or Canada and the arm
now does not contain significant lengths
of smallpox DNA the possession of large
amounts of smallpox DNA now is
completely forbidden and controlled by
the World Health Organization so the arm
itself is a legal smallpox arm but I
went in there with a group and and
looked at the arm and held it in my
hands and described it and took notes
and it was a very impressive
demonstration of the reality of smallpox
and really hits you in the face when you
see the arm of a child this child had
died of a confluent smallpox these
pustules had virtually merged over the
hand until the hand was nothing but
solid wall to wall pustules and I the
hand is small and I recalled I have
three kids and I recall when they were
smaller hole sometimes holding their
hands in mind and watching how the
child's hand over time grows and how
gradually it becomes an adult hand if
you watch it over time and I also
thought a lot about how we as parents
protect our children and try to do
everything we can to keep them safe and
I thought about this child who would not
there was nothing that could have been
done to keep this child safe so I'm
going to rather this parasite this
life-form had destroyed this child and I
felt as though I was coming into contact
with a human reality that was absolutely
real to Americans into everybody 50
years ago a hundred years ago when
smallpox really was in families when it
was something that took children away
when ordinary people had experienced our
forbearers even our great grandparents
may very well have seen smallpox with
their own eyes they may indeed have
suffered and endured the loss and their
own families of people from smallpox and
I felt as I held his hand that that we
brought ourselves to a very peculiar
pass as a species that we the human
species had every right and reason and
need to cause this virus to become
extinct to become to cease to exist as a
life form on the planet and for a little
while we had the opportunity to do it
there was a time in the early 1980s when
as da Henderson who led the eradication
of smallpox said to me we could have
destroyed the publicly owned stocks of
smallpox we could have done it we could
have talked the Russians into it we
could have done it and he said to me in
effect I just don't know why we didn't
do it and Henderson's point is that
there may have been other secret stocks
of smallpox around the world even a
nineteen eighty in fact there were but
bye-bye at least publicly destroying the
smallpox we of what we knew existed we
could Henderson's argument is that we
could have made a statement to the whole
world that we can get along without
smallpox we don't need smallpox and we
would have made smallpox that much more
of Horan to everybody so that a nation
in possession of smallpox would become a
true pariah and that in a way might help
as Henderson said to me improve the
moral climate but we didn't do it and
the virus today is I think without
question a weapon it is a strategic
weapon by strategic what that means is
that
has effects on human populations as a
whole it's not a targeted tactical
weapon smallpox as a weapon is a weapon
of mass destruction of a very certain
kind it's a weapon that from very small
beginnings knows how to make copies of
itself inside the human body in there by
to move through human populations
plutonium does not know how to make
copies of itself smallpox is alive it's
a life-form that biologists some in the
world have perverted into a weapon and
they preferred their own field and
they've disgraced themselves as
biologists and yet this is what they
have done and when we think back on the
development of nuclear weapons no nation
that ever wanted to have nuclear weapons
for whatever reason was unable to find
physicists who are very willing to make
them for their governments and the same
is true in biology today any nation that
wants biological weapons can undoubtedly
find PhD biologists who are willing to
do it that was never a problem in the
past and it won't be a problem in the
future and so we're left with this this
peculiar and I think essentially tragic
state of affairs we're in order to keep
ourselves safe from this virus we have
to keep it around not only that we have
to awaken it we have to thought take it
out of the freezer use it and do
experiments with it because that's the
only way we can understand it well
enough scientifically to know how to
protect ourselves from it in the event
that someone uses it as a weapon the
the message in the in the demon in the
freezer if there is a message apart from
the fact that it's a story I tell
stories because stories convey a lot all
at once and people come away from
stories with very different ideas and
feelings but if there is a message the
message has got to be something to the
effect that that that we as a species
are at the verge of controlling nature
in a new way that we have never been
able to do before that in fact the
biologists of our time are beginning to
find themselves somewhat like the
nuclear physicists the position of the
nuclear physicists in say the late 1930s
when it was becoming a parent to some
leading physicists that whether they
liked it or not it was going to become
possible to harness the forces of nature
to create an absolutely massive
explosion a release of energy a bomb and
when they thought about that they
realized that most likely somebody was
going to try it and then when the second
world war broke out it was Albert
Einstein himself who in a letter to
President Roosevelt urged the United
States to proceed immediately with the
development of a bomb to do it before
Germany did one wonders what the future
holds really with biology I don't feel
that we're entering a time of doom and i
dont preach doom at all and if you look
at my stories and read my books you find
that again and again they are about
people who do noble things and sometimes
complex difficult stressful but
ultimately good things and I write about
Americans these are people who I know
well and like to write about and one
reason I like to write about Americans
is because Americans have an in
a sense of possibility for themselves in
their culture their society and we are
an extremely resilient and resourceful
nation we are protected by people who do
know what they are doing and I would
like to mention the Centers for Disease
Control is one of those kinds of places
the CDC is an incredible asset for the
United States an incredible asset not
only for the US but for global public
health the CDC without ever really being
asked to do it has found it a good thing
in a mission to look after the public
health of the world population as a
whole because after all what happens in
other countries can also happen here in
the United States there is a reason for
it but it's also just a very good thing
we have an absolute jewel of an asset
here in the United States that I hope is
appreciated and with with with
organizations like that and with clever
people who are able to think outside the
box and and try new things if something
doesn't work Americans are really good
at trying something else we tend to
react very reactively to a crisis we're
never very good at preparing for / doom
we don't naturally like to believe in
doom actually we we like to carry on our
lives as best we can and I feel very
confident that if there is an outbreak
of smallpox in this country which could
happen but no one knows whether it will
happen or not that we can in fact handle
it we can deal with it it will be bad I
think but I think also we can come
through this country has once you know
many times in the past come through the
cauldron of challenge and we've always
come out a stronger country and a better
people the bad thing about nonfiction
writing from the point of view of a
writer is that the story has to come to
an
because the publisher is demanding that
you published the book this happened to
me with my publisher Random House they
really twisted my arm on this one and in
the end like the previous books that
they literally ripped the page proofs
out of my hands I was working on the
page proofs of this book three days
before it went to the printer which is
very unusual and in a situation like
that you end up phoning in calling
people up and saying okay I want to add
a sentence I want to change this I've
got new information and it goes on and
on but in the end what you have is you
have a snapshot of human lives in time
and you have some deeds that may or may
not be important which I think are and
you have a piece of history in your
hands the sad thing for me as a writer
is of course the human lives always go
on people continue to develop your
characters know how to read your books
they react to what you wrote with
outrage or pleasure or whatever it may
be and and then they change and they
develop as characters and what you have
is a sense of history as being you know
the writer is looking at little feeder
streams of history there all draining
into the great river of history which
flows along through time it eventually
becomes the history of our country and
our nation long after we are gone thank
you very much
people have one or two questions that
they would like to ask I invite to
questions or comments and if you could
go to the microphone to ask your
questions so people can hear it
thanks
followed you up there on the balcony to
should ask a few questions
do we have anybody in particular who has
any thought okay yes yes there um I'm
just wondering what you feel the media
is rolling in like prevention of
bioterrorism and stuff sorry could you
ask that question again I'm sorry this
thing on there you go um what you think
the media's role in a preventing
bioterrorism keeping public informed
what's the role of the media and keeping
the public informed and preventing
bioterrorism well I don't want to claim
a super heroic role for the news media
the news media sometimes likes to claim
that for itself and I won't add to the
chorus I really don't know quite how to
answer that question I think perhaps the
way to answer it is to say that that we
live in a country where people are
guaranteed certain rights under the
Constitution and one of them is the
freedom of expression and that's I can
get up and and put my two cents into a
book and people can read my opinions for
better or worse so they can read my
story for better or worse at least in
terms of my own role as a journalist I
tend to stay away from being a policy
wonk and making wonky wonky
recommendations about one thing or
another I've been staying away from
questions like exactly how should we
vaccinate the public you know should we
start war with Iraq if they have this
terrible smallpox what should we be
doing I really stay away from questions
like that seems to me that at least from
my role as a journalist what I can do is
tell a compelling story and then let
people deal with it what they want
people are intelligent and they're
probably going to do different things
with the story but that's one way to to
to answer people's questions and feed
the spirit in a way I don't know if I
answered your question but I try it I
guess
any more questions yes I'm just curious
um in your discussions with the experts
what did they said about those of us
that have already had the vaccine when
we were kids I mean how do we know we're
not already immune uh it cuz it's my
understanding that if we don't have an
animal model we can't test it like the
tighter like we do with other vaccines I
mean what have you heard well I don't
think there's any reliable way to know
you're immune to smallpox unless you get
exposed to it and don't get it or get it
I mean that's the practical way to test
but we're not going to do that the the
consensus view seems to be that the
vaccine tends to wear off and many
people starting about five years after
the vaccination many people over the age
of 30 were vaccinated as children and
they many of them will have a little
scar on their upper left arm about the
size of a dimer and nickel this is the
scar a single pustule it was raised by
the vaccine during the vaccination the
vaccine is a mild virus called vaccinia
which infects you and in doing so it
causes your immune system to go into a
state of screaming alarm and it can't
tell the difference between this mod
vaccinia virus and smallpox so if you
get exposed to smallpox your immune
system will will fight it off that's how
the vaccine works so I don't think
there's any way to know answer your
question except that there is a general
I think scientific consensus that the
vaccine wears off in different people at
different rates but does tend to wear
off yes yes well you may have said that
you're not going to answer this question
already but I'm not gonna let that stop
me from asking us that's the way but let
me let me preface it by saying that I
was with the smallpox eradication
campaign in India so I have seen cases
of smallpox where was thinking wait here
my name is Dan Blumenthal okay I'm at
Morehouse okay um you've told us a
little bit about the the Russian or the
Soviet rather buy a weapon
a program in which we knew they had
smallpox virus yeah they were a powerful
enemy with ICBMs into which
theoretically I guess they could have
loaded smallpox virus we and we knew
they had it we knew they had this
bioweapons program and yet in the 1980s
there was no real suggestion that we
should undertake even small-scale
vaccination let alone mass vaccination
now here we are in 2002 we don't
actually know that anybody has smallpox
virus outside of the two labs we have no
powerful enemies they're pretty ragtag
bunch really is certainly they don't
have any ICBMs and yet we are now
hearing recommendations that 50,000
people will be vaccinated or a half a
million or a million or perhaps
everybody so my question is where we
really being stupid then or are really
being stupid down
a great question thank you for asking I
I'll say that we were ignorant back then
we actually didn't know in the 1980s US
intelligence had no clue that the Soviet
Union had gone so far in the
weaponization of smallpox we really no
clue at all and it wasn't until a series
of defectors first ladda mere possession
akin 1989 and then cannella beck and
there's been more than that came out and
began talking to British intelligence
first and then to the CIA and this
information was gradually disclosed I
think today there's still insufficient
knowledge of what the Soviets did and
the Russian Federation has been most
unforced error in firm ation there was
an inspection process that was going on
that was begun in the early 1990s there
was quite similar to the inspection
process that was done in Iraq by the
United Nations and the Russian
government shut it down and there are at
least two military sites in the Soviet
and former Soviet Union both about 50
miles from Moscow that were allegedly
stockpiling the virus in large
quantities in the late 1980s and to this
day to my knowledge US and British
inspectors have never been allowed to go
into those sites and see what's there
and they've been stonewalled so I'm not
sure that's an answer your question but
in any case we just didn't know back
then in addition to that I think there
was a general feeling of well-being
about the biological weapons convention
the treaty of 1972 signed by the United
States in 1972 that governs and controls
biological weapons Snyder's of the
treaty are not allowed to possess the
develop biological weapons the BWC the
biological weapons convention was held
up for many years as
a stellar example of the success of arms
control one of the few efforts of arms
control that really worked and the
argument was repeatedly advanced that
the reason that the BWC worked was
because fundamentally biological weapons
don't work as weapons they're
ineffective they either go wildly out of
control so they can't be used as weapons
or they just simply don't work put him
in the air and nobody gets sick these
were beliefs on the part of the
scientific community that were not
supported by any evidence whatsoever
they were simply beliefs but the
scientific community is entitled to its
police and has many unexamined beliefs
but when all this information came out
here has gradually been a global shift
of thinking and now I think the feeling
is that that that some biological
weapons are pretty obviously quite
effective but they still the worst ones
like smallpox still have this tendency
to just go out of control from all we
know so the question is I mean this is
often raised why would any nation even a
nation is crazy as Iraq you know release
smallpox is just going to affect
everybody what point is that well I'm
not so sure that that's really the kind
of thinking that prevails in countries
like that for one thing think about the
development at the hydrogen bomb the
hydrogen bomb is 100 times more powerful
than the bomb that leveled Hiroshima and
it was independently invented in the
united states by edward teller and in
the soviet union by andrei sakharov they
both sincerely believed what they called
the super bomb was a good thing for
their countries even though it was
absolutely overwhelmingly davis
dating is a weapon far more so than than
the Hiroshima bomb and secondly as
physicist they were both intellectually
attracted to the challenge of building
the bomb it was a pure quest given that
who are we to say it biologists in other
countries might not be driven by the
same kind of reasoning any more
questions all right thank you very much
and we're gonna proceed to a book
signing I think Richard Preston's the
demon in the freezer is published by
Random House online at Random House com